jonathan cubaine est ce qu'on appelle un
créateur de contenus un influenceur il
ya trois ans ce grand voyageur lance une
campagne pour rassurer sa maman avec le
mot-clic mom and frank g à travers le
monde toujours en disant on est dans des
situations soit par an soit un peu
effrayante veux dire ma marge allait
bien avec des requins en ce temps là et
c'est partout où ils passent moman fine
devient virale il annonce alors fin 2010
est la création de sa ligne de vêtements
pour 2018
mais il découvre que la compagnie
montréalaise rythme hans le devance et
lens temporairement le même type de
campagne au printemps 2010 8 ils ont
familles environ jean t-shirt plus de
200 mille sacs la même police la même
couleur tout au tout quand on s'habille
rettman le contacte alors pour discuter
elle décide de suspendre sa campagne sur
les réseaux sociaux une semaine après
son lancement mais pas les ventes comme
en atteste ce document de juin 2018 et
pendant les échanges de courriels redman
va même jusqu'à déposer au canada la
marque
moman fine le 27 avril 2018 un coup dur
pour jonathan qui avait déposé le nom
dans toute l'europe mais part ça se
passe super bien
réponse des écouteurs voilà on voit ce
que l'on parle par mail et de licence
rétroactive et devoirs en poste qu'il
est possible de faire ensemble peut-être
même un partenariat et puis au final les
avocats s'en mêle elle a tout tombe par
terre
nous avons fait une demande d'entrevue à
la compagnie rythme hans mais elle a
préféré répondre par voie de communiqué
elle estime que la campagne a été mise
en place de façon légale et légitime
qu'elle respecte le travail des
influenceurs et qu'elle a entrepris un
dialogue respectueux avec jonathan
cubaine et qu'il n'a pas répondu à leur
dernière communication de juillet 2018
devant l'impasse j'en attends a coupé
court
dil rythme hans ne proposait rien en
terme d'indemnisation ni de
reconnaissance de la paternité de la
campagne d'un point de vue moral d'un
point de vue financier ça m'a conté
avant cas sont à côté des ventes ça m'a
conté plein de choses l'inspiration des
tendances dans le domaine de la mode
cela ne date pas d'hier
ils vont également montré la copie est
historique
mais les marques peuvent elles
cannibaliser des concepts empruntés à
autrui
oui un problème d'éthique longs grecs et
a tellement grande échelle que ya
pratiquement rien à faire fondre seul et
ce phénomène toucherait aussi certaines
entreprises québécoises
ces grandes boutiques l'heure ce sont
des championnes de la copie ils ont même
al interne des gens dont la définition
de tâche est de parcourir le monde à la
recherche de modèles qui pourraient
ensuite être copie sous l'étiquette
maison c'est ça leur job de fer sur
l'aspect identiques ou similaires n'y a
pas de question c'est identique
cet avocat spécialisé en marque déposée
pense que la cause de l'influencé est
solide mais ce sera david contre goliath
c'est sûr qu'il va devoir engendré des
frais pour effectivement faire cette
opposition l'un et éventuellement faire
un recours pour demander des dommages
pour moi c'est le projet d'une vie j'ai
vendu ma voiture j'ai vendu plein de
choses pour pouvoir faire ça et pardon
rettman se dit ouvert de nouveau au
dialogue mais jonathan cubaine a tant
que l'entreprise le contact il s'excuse
ici frédéric arnould radio canada
montréal